this question I like to think of
questions sometimes like a river right
some rivers are really wide but there
are only an inch deep they just take you
a lot of time under questions they're
only you know the government is of
course but there's super deep in your
like I don't even know how to get
through this question this question is a
mile wide okay
is it the use of the same skill
basically quite repetitively and if you
can sort of see through how intimidating
the question is and just start to chip
away it is not that complicated at all I
want to point out a skill which I
demonstrate up here which kind of ends
up being the key skill here do you
notice I wrote this as forty nine to the
half rather than the square root of 49
even though they are the same thing when
I'm dealing with logs why is 49 to the
power of 1/2 why is that instrumentally
more useful to me because I can see the
power very clearly right we use square
roots all the time so that's why it
earns its own form of notation but when
you're dealing with logs the thing
you're actually looking for is the power
right so I'm going to do the same thing
down here
I want to write every number I possibly
can in terms of a power rather than in
terms of square roots or even in terms
of a number like 243 that's a number
raised to a power right so let's start
to chip away at this if you have a look
at this 3 the cube root of 3 I'm going
to start from the deepest part right how
would I write that as a power that's 3
the power of 1/3 right so I'm just going
to write that even you now that is being
multiplied by something what's it being
multiplied by so there are there are
more square roots to go I just want to
focus on this little number so this 81
here is a power of 3 isn't it you can
think about this in terms of like that's
9 squared which is 3 squared squares so
therefore it's 3 to the 4 do you agree
so those two things are being multiplied
together but then both of them have a
square root applied to them so what
power should I put there well huh now
that square root is the multiplied by
this thing well this thing is just 3
times bigger than that so what power of
3 will that be
it'll be 3 to the 5 rates one bigger and
then all of that is also you can excuse
me having a square root
taken out of it so far so good log base
3 of that okay then you look at the
denominator same kind of deal you have a
look and you see okay where can I take
powers out of this that'll be useful
I've got log base 2 of what 64 that's 2
to the power of 6 to the power of 6 so
familiarity comes from dealing with
these questions a lot which is why the
practice is up being so forth important
you've got to the power of 6 here but
they've taken the 4th root of that
number so what power is that raising it
to I'll call out right by the time you
get to this last term on the denominator
they were trying to give you a bit of a
hand they're like ok we'll give you the
power on this one we won't expect you to
recognize what I've 5 of a power of
negative 10 is so seeing that's already
in power power form what do I do with it
you can bring out the front and make up
the coefficient so that's minus 10 do
you agree log file to the 5 are you okay
with that from here it's just a bit of
number crunching really so for example
if you have a look at the denominator
down here 2 to the power of 6 to the
power of 1/4 what's that going to be to
the power of 6 on 4 which is to just
have 3 on 2 do you agree and we've just
taken log base 2 of that you can see
where this is going to go have a look at
this what's this log base 5 of 5 going
to be 1 so I just get that and then up
here I just have to do some crunching
okay so what are we going to have here I
can I can bring that half out the front
I can bring back half also I know I
can't that's not applied to the whole
thing I should probably start from the
inside so this is 4 and 1/3 so what do
you do when you multiply numbers with
the same base you add their powers right
so what's that going to be 4 4 and a
third is 13 third
that's three to the power 13 thirds that
thing has had a half applied to it which
is your x before that's right on there
right no it's a fight that's a 5 I've
already done before haven't I
that thing has had the power of 1/2
applied to it and I'm just sort of going
to keep climbing down right what am i up
to now when you raise a power to a power
you don't add the powers what do you do
you multiply them right so in there
you're going to have what 3 to power 13
on six
yeah yeah
yes that's impossible I'd buy 3 to the 5
and that's had a half taken out of it
what have I got on the bottom that's 3
on to take away 10 do you already see
what I mean by this is a long question
so you're using the same skills over and
over again so that's not what makes it
hard you just have to have patience and
be accurate with your manipulations do
you want to know what the answer is at
the bottom yeah
once you finish let's have a look once
you finish you'll get this so maybe on
your own book you may want to jot that
down to see if you end up finishing out
this question letting up there